Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
Netflix released an official teaser
for One Piece Season 2.
Oda himself has some really specific
characters like Chopper.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch of Easter Eggs here.
other cool thing that you may have seen
recently is the cast of one
piece was hoping that Jamie
Lee Curtis would play Kureha.
this is actually Jamie
Lee Curtis legit talking about wanting
to play the character during the one piece
Netflix season two.
Watch one piece. It's a no,
but my favorite characters.
Tony, Tony, Chopper Love friend
Breena Palencia does
the voice of Tony
Tony Chopper in the American Dub.
Really? Yeah.
Wow. Okay,
So your favorite characters. Tony.
Tony Shopper.
I remember you specifically
saying who you would like to play
and want to name Nico
Robin.
Yeah, well, I'm not going to get to.
I'm a little old, but, you know,
there's that wizened old crone lady.
Not Nico. Robin, the one that woman.
Courageous.
You want to be.
I can be courageous.
Ooh, like, really low bellbottoms.
She's looking a little nasty, but
she has a long kind of stringy gray hair.
And my ruby said that
that would be what I would play.
Oh, I love.
I can totally see that.
But she has that dream.
She's super charismatic.
She's a she's the mother mother
figure up top.
Yeah. Yeah.
the funny thing about that is that Jamie
Lee Curtis was talking about wanting to be
in one piece way before the cast
was actually talking about it.
Like,
this is the actress who plays NAMI saying
that she would love for Jamie
Lee Curtis to be in the series,
but she didn't know about the Jamie Lee
Curtis video when she posted this.
there's also the idea that Jamie Lee
Curtis herself was also already connected
to the world of one piece
through the anime series in her friend
being the dub actor
for Chopper's character,
who they are introducing
during season 2 according to Oda.
I also think it's funny
that she previously wanted
to be Nico Robin,
but like she very honest about this.
Like, you know what?
I've kind of aged out of the role.
Like I'm a little bit too old for Nico.
Robin I'd be Nico Robin from one piece,
but I don't know.
I know
you don't know fabulous Tony,
Tony chopper.
Now you have the body to.
I'm so excited about my Tony
Tony chopper present.
I love Tony.
Tony Travers,
my favorite character in one piece.
Have you watched all of it?
Yes, Everything, actually. Yes.
So who's that old, wizened woman?
Where's the low cut bell bottom?
He wants me to play that woman.
Now Kureha is like her backup,
so I'll be doing bonus videos
for one season two as Netflix releases
more footage and teasers.
So be sure to subscribe to get all those.
It'll be a while
before season two happens.
during the teaser, Oda is very gracious
that Netflix decided to renew the show,
but I think we all kind of
expected them to do it was super popular.
the big surprise, though, is that they
decided to announce it officially so soon
instead of waiting till after the strike,
because they can't start filming
till after the strike is done.
The showrunner said that
they had written scripts for season two
before the strike started.
It sounds like what Netflix did
when they picked up season one is
they told them to prepare season two,
expecting that they'd renew it eventually.
just kind of waiting
to see how season one went
before they actually formally did that.
the showrunner claimed that
when they made the deal for season one,
they plotted out season two in season
three in a very detailed way.
They have a really solid idea of what
those seasons will adapt from the manga.
ba ba.
On season three, they only have loose
concepts about what that's going to be.
even though if you've read the manga,
you have a pretty solid idea
of how the story progresses
They did say they want to adapt
all the manga depending on
when Oda decides to end the Manga,
you'd have a chance if they're going to
speedrun entire sagas with each season
and based on their initial outline
for what
season
two and season three are going to be,
it sounds like that's
what they're going to do
Oda says the scripts for season
two need some polishing.
The showrunner also said
they wouldn't start filming
until after the strike,
but to expect Season two
in about 18 months or so if things go
well the next couple of months.
My assumption, just based on the way
things are going.
Netflix will release it around
summer 2025.
the major new thing the OTA was teasing
during the trailer was Tony Tony Chopper.
During the series,
he said that the going Mary could use
the good doctor chopper does wind up
becoming the straw hats doctor during
the series The real big question though
everyone had was how they were going to do
the chopper character.
Will he be a special effect like CG
or would he be more like a muppet?
Look at the character like Grogu
who on The Mandalorian.
That's play a good template
some of the time when they're filming
with the Grogu character for episodes.
They used the physical puppet in scenes,
and sometimes he's just completely CG.
you can kind of spot the differences
if you rewatch the episodes
really, really closely.
But they're getting pretty good at
blending both versions of the character.
my assumption is because Netflix
is spending so much money on this new
one piece series is
they'll do the same thing
they do for Grogu
for the chopper character.
He'll just be part
puppet and part CG, just depending on
what he's doing in scenes.
Chopper comes from Drum Island
in the Grand Line.
It's a winter island
renowned for its good doctors.
The courageous character
that Jamie Lee Curtis was talking about
in wants to Play is Chopper's adoptive
mother and his mentor Netflix loves.
They love putting big celebrities
in shows like this.
So they probably jumped on the phone
the second that they saw
the clip of Jamie Lee Curtis talking about
wanting to be in the series.
So as long as Oda is on board with her
playing, the character in, it could work
at a financial deal with her.
It sounds like it should work out.
But Netflix can't make any kind of deals
like that till after the strike is over.
So, like,
we probably won't hear anything about her
potentially joining the series for months.
the other reason why she was talking about
wanting to play Nico Robin, even though
that was a long time ago during season two
is because they also introduced
the Nico Robin character during season
two through the broke works storyline.
Season two, is largely going to adapt
the Alabasta saga from the manga.
Some people call it
the Arabasta saga.
You can call it whichever you want.
Originally the manga referred to it
as Alabasta, so most people who do that
in present day are people who just read
the manga back in the day.
they also refer to the second saga
sometimes as the Baroque works saga
because they're the main antagonist
driving the main plot forward
the entire season.
Crocodile is their leader.
He's one of the seven warlords like me.
Hawk His grand plan
is to create a perfect kingdom.
And he created the Baroque works
organization to do that.
But really, his secret goal in season
two is just take over the Alabasta
kingdom and become its ruler
within the world of one piece.
The Alabasta kingdom is kind of
like a stand in for the Middle East.
It's like a desert kingdom wood
they'll probably do in
episode one is a combination of Loguetown
and verse mountain.
That's what the teaser Post-Credits
scene was for during the finale.
The man was Captain Smoker
looking at Luffy's wanted poster.
Season
one was meant to adapt the East Blue Saga
Loguetown
is like the end of that in the manga,
but the showrunners said
that they just ran out of money,
like they ran out of budgets.
They had to leave Loguetown for season two.
they'll probably do
a speed run version of Loguetown
at the beginning of episode
one where Luffy, the straw hat, show up.
They pay off a bunch of references
back to season one,
he meets Captain Smoker
Vivi Buggy returns with Alvida Loguetown
is a really important place in the one
piece universe for a lot of reasons.
Like Loguetown was featured
in the first episode of the series
because that's where Goldy Rodger
originally came from.
That's also where he was killed by Luffy's
grandfather.
practically.
It's also really important
because it's the last stop on the way
to the grand line before reverse Mountain.
So any ship wanting to travel to the grand
line has to pass through Loguetown.
Captain Smoker
is the Marine leader of this area.
He sees his wanted poster
wanting to take Luffy down
just because their whole thing
is arresting pirates.
Smoker also has Devil Fruit powers.
His powers
allow him to create control and transform
any part of his body into smoke.
If you're a fan of Avatar
The Last Airbender
and Netflix is doing a live action avatar
The Last Airbender series,
like I just did a trailer video for it.
smokers powers
would be kind of like Airbending, but
just for smoke That's
why he's always smoking so much.
Like, why would you smoke two cigars
unless that was part of some base power
set that you had?
How fast do you want
to give yourself cancer?
They'll probably have Luby's rematch
with Boogie and Alveda,
who's gotten her
slip Slip Devil Fruit Powers.
they kind of tease
that at the end of season
one with Alveda
wanting to join Luffy's crew.
They basically team up.
Louie,
Louie in the Straw has also run into Vivi
who is one of the most important
new characters in season two.
Just in general,
she is the princess of the Alabasta
Kingdom and secretly infiltrated
Baroque works, hoping to stop them
from taking over her kingdom.
she starts out as an antagonist
to Lupi in the straw hats,
but eventually joins the crew
for the remainder of that saga.
which will probably be episode one,
was to kill the giant whale for its meat
Luffy and the others
prevent her from doing that.
And because the whale so important
for other arcs way later in the
other characters way later in the manga,
I think they'll probably do him
at some point during episode one.
maybe a really quick scene,
but it just makes sense
to include the giant whale,
Then they'll probably
just do Reverse Mountain
for like the second half of the episode.
episode two will probably be Whiskey Peak
where they encounter broke works.
Vivi becomes a bigger part of the team.
they also introduce
Nico Robin here in the manga,
so they might do that on the series,
but she doesn't actually join the crew
full on till after the end of
what would be the season two finale.
Basically that'll be some of their teaser
for season three at the end of the season
two finale, Episode three will probably be
at least most of or some of little
Island maybe some of Drum Island too
where chopper becomes the straw hats.
Doctor
They arrive at the island
in the middle of a Game of Thrones
power struggle,
but there's a bunch of little islands
that they happened before that.
I don't know how quickly
they're going to speedrun
that the whole thing with Little Island
is it's kind of like Jurassic Park
in the one piece universe.
The island is stuck in the past, basically
with dinosaurs all over the place.
there are a bunch of giants
that live there.
So the name A Little Island
is meant to be ironic They'll probably use
all of episode four Episode
five to cover all of the Drum Island arc.
Luffy winds up having to do battle
with Wapole,
whose family used to rule the island.
They they have a big Game of Thrones
power struggle where he tries to return
and take control again
and they have to prevent that.
then episode six through episode eight.
Like basically the rest of the show,
the second half of the show will probably
be all of the old boss two arc
where they actually start traveling there
with Vivi to stop a baroque works
episode seven will probably be
where they actually have their big battle
with the straw hats versus
everyone from Baroque works in episode
eight
will probably be Luffy versus Crocodile
and then teasing Season 3,
which will be the Skypiea saga.
basically the Sky Island saga.
A lot of people were joking about this
after they released season one, like
this is going to break
Netflix is budget, but
I'm sure they'll figure out how to do it.
just address what's going to happen
beyond season three.
I do think Netflix will give it at least 4
to 5 seasons.
Beyond that,
Netflix has a terrible track record
with renewing shows for longer periods.
Stranger Things, for example,
is an exception, not the rule.
really hoping that they give them
at least seven seasons
to do as many of the one piece
arcs as possible.
My assumption is they can't do that.
Then they'll try to speedrun the most
essential parts of the later manga
so they can give the show
the same kind of ending as the manga.
But if Oda hasn't ended it yet, they might
have to do a series original ending.
If they don't just end
at some earlier point in the manga.
this is a very Game of Thrones,
a song of ice and fire kind of problem.
Like HBO
had to end the Game of Thrones series
before the Song of Ice and Fire novels.
It was based on ended.
So they kind of had to do a series
original ending with like one plot point
that George R.R.
Martin had told them, The only part about
the original book ending the George R.R.
Martin revealed to the showrunners
was that Bran would become king.
Everything else was basically original
to the show.
The one piece Netflix showrunner,
the producers, pretty much
the entire cast
are all such super fans of the one piece.
I don't think they're going to do that
for the Netflix series.
I think that they'll work out
something with Oda,
let me know in the comments
if they do have to end the show
before Oda ends the manga,
how do you want them to end the show?
post all your season
two predictions in the comments
and I'll do more one pieces in two videos
when they release more information
or an official season two teaser.
But they're probably not going to do that.
At least Netflix wouldn't announce it
until after the strike is done.
click here for my one piece, Season one
Post-Credits scene video and click here
for my Avatar The Last Airbender
Netflix Trailer Video in Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!